welcome to today's live broadcast
comprehensive characterization of a
monoclonal antibody in a single analysis
I'm Stephanie L from the division of
medical Sciences at the University of
Victoria and I'll be moderating your
webinar today we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab BRS and sponsored by CX
separations a part of ab CX capillary
electris and liquid chromatography are
among the most powerful analytical tools
available to scientists today ABX is
expanding the power of these
Technologies by combining back Bing
culture capillary electri
and exent liquid chromatography to
create the business unit Sak separations
particular capillary electri frus
instruments and all liquid
chromatography instruments are designed
for connectivity to Mass teters from ABX
and other leading manufacturers for more
information please visit
www.x
cex.com
before we get to today's presentation I
have a few announcements this webcast is
designed to be interactive and we
encourage you to ask questions during
the event you can submit questions by
typing them in the question and answer
box which is found by clicking the green
Q&A button in the lower left of the
presentation window and we're going to
try and answer as many questions today
as we can you can energe the slide
window by clicking on the screen icon in
the lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems or hearing this presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of your presentation
window or submit your problem through
the green Q&A button in the lower
left our present our presenter today is
B fonso he received his PhD in
analytical chemistry from the University
of Minnesota where he worked with
Professor Michael T Bowser developing
micro micro freeflow electroforesis for
bioanalytical separations and assays his
interest is in applying mass mass
spectrometry to bioanalytical
separations and this led him to a
post-doctoral position in the laboratory
of John R Yates III at the scripts
Research Institute he is now an
application scientist with the Sak
separations and a professional research
collaborator with script the scripts
Research Institute his current work
focuses on applying capillary electr
freesis separations and Mass spectromet
spectrometry to the analysis of proteins
and post translational
modifications and with that I'm going to
turn our presentation now over to
Brian thank you for the nice
introduction Stephanie good morning
everyone thank you again for joining us
uh today I'm going to be talking about
comprehensive analysis characterization
of a monal antibody in a single
analysis and if you're joining us you're
probably well aware of the challenges of
characterizing monoclinal antibodies due
to their complexity particularly those
of therapeutic nature since there's a
number of different modifications that
are introduced both biologically and
purposefully to improve
efficacy uh I'll so I'll briefly
highlight some of those challenges
and talk about how we have current
Solutions using capit electrophoresis
for the characterization of these monoc
antibodies in
biopharma and then I'll talk briefly
about linking CE to mass spectrometry
particularly for the Improvement of uh
sensitivity and dynamic range in some of
these
analyses uh this this then will lead
into our cesi technology and u talk
about the application of this in the
characterization of a monoc monoclonal
antibody and then at the end I'll just
Briefly summarize what I've what I've
talked
about so as I mentioned and as you
probably are well aware monocom
antibodies have a large number of
modifications on them that really
contribute to their complexity and also
to the challenges in characterizing
them uh these types of modifications can
be uh
critical quality attributes if they
are end up leading to issues with
efficacy patient safety or degradation
of the monoc antibodies and these are
really just potential a list of
potential quality attributes that can
become critical if they they actually
contribute to any of those those issues
with monoc
antibody
so to better describe these
modifications you can see uh some of
them listed here such as pyroglutamate
formation
uh decorative post translation
modification such as deamidation
oxidation glycosilation isomerization
and many others listed here so these are
some of the post transational
modifications we'll be talking about
today um and just to briefly highlight
you know there's both as I mentioned
these types of modifications that are
introduced biologically and also those
that can be introduced throughout the
process so we're very interested in
being able to use cap electr fores to to
monitor these these modifications
throughout the the process and
generation of these these monoc Coral
antibodies so this slide reiterates a
bit of that concept um essentially the
figure on the left shows very similar
modifications sh shown on this this
monol antibody and I'll point you to
this reference of the bottom if if you
are not entirely aware of many of these
modifications but essentially there's a
number of monoclone antibodies that have
these modifications and now with the
introduction of other monoclone
antibodies such as biosimilar and biobs
which are acting to mimic some of the
therapeutic monoclonal antibodies that
have been on the market and coming off
patent and also adcs such as antibody
drug conjugates which are um adding
an additional organic molecule typically
to the to the monol antibody to improve
efficacy and potentially
safety so the figure on the right
actually starts to illustrate some of
those instances also and really to
summarize this this concept essentially
the Improvement of monol antibodies is
actually making them more difficult to
characterize so by adding either F or
unintended modifications through these
processes it becomes more important to
characterize them and have technologies
that are uh have greater sensitivity and
dynamic range for for these
analyses the captic deis is a an
analytical separation science in itself
and in the case of monoc antibodies it
actually has a lot of advantages um so
I'll briefly describe capillaris in
general for those that may be unfamiliar
with
it so the Capal electris has the basis
of the separation is through different
differential migration of molecules in
an applied electric field so you can see
in this upper figure on the right uh
there's an electroosmotic flow that's
generated I'll try to use this Arrow
here to point this
out so by applying an electric field you
actually have this electroosmotic flow
Genera this is the bulk flow in cap
electris unlike nanolc or other LC
methods that use pressure D flow and so
one of the advantages of this is it
gives a flat flow profile which gives
you very good efficiency in your
separation so in addition to separating
Things based on charge as shown in this
image uh by applying this electric field
you are also getting very efficiencies
and so this is shown in this comparison
between um Peaks from Capal electris and
in this case a high performance like
chromati preparation so Capal electris
in general is a more efficient
separation technique and to go back to
this upper figure the electroosmotic
flow is used to actually drive generally
it's used to drive the all of the
molecules through a detector through a
detection window or out the end of the
the capillary in the instance of mass
spectrometry with electrospray
ionization there's other advantages in
terms of small injection volumes and
also U minim minimal run buffer
requirements and there's a number of
different modes of catho Electro pris
which I'll begin to describe shortly
that gives good separation flexibility
for different types of analyses and
ultimately it's a automated quantitative
technique so I'll highlight in a couple
slides how the fact that it's automated
and quantitative makes it a great
alternative an improvement to doing
separations with gel electric
Braes so these are the current uh kits
that we we have for this established
assessment of idg Purity and
heterogenity and these all use capillar
electropheresis so in the first case uh
lower left
uh this is a a kit that's used for doing
SDS gel electroforesis which allows you
to do Purity and heterogenity Analysis
of a monoc antibody both in the intact
and reduced forms in the middle there's
also isoelectric focusing kit that
allows you to do charge heterogen
analysis and on the right is a glycan
analysis kit which allows you to do a
glycan or carbohydrate profiling
analysis for a monoc antibody and that
is of the release gly can so there's a
number of kits here already that have
that have proven quite useful in
biofarma and I would urge you to look
further into these if you're having
current challenges with some of the the
methodologies you
Ed here's some examples of the results
you might expect from those type of
analyses as I mentioned um the
improvement over gel elector freeze this
slab G
electris uh there's a a an image here
showing a separation of a monocom
antibody Lees the reduced form showing
the heavy and light chains and the
comparison to that with capillary gel
electris so you can see you get a very
similar profile and in this case it's
automated and quanitative similarly
there's the CIF and also an analogous
capillary Zone Electro pesis kit which
allows you to do ched charge heterogen
analysis and this works quite well for
determining isoelectric points of
uh charge isoforms in your of your mon
antibody and finally the glycan analysis
kit which allows you to profile the
released and fluorescently labeled uh
glycans from your monoclonal and just to
to highlight this C has become starting
to become a gold standard for these type
of analyses um as Illustrated in this
lower box here showing that USP actually
suggests this as a in
revisions of methods to include these
type of
methodologies another nice advantage of
using C is that it's it's uh reliable
robust and transportable across sites so
you can see from a number of
Publications here and a few that were
were presented at C farm and pending
publication that generally all of these
methods with capital electri freesis can
be used across
different continents and among different
companies to to characterize these these
monol antibodies so this will become
more and more important especially with
uh the biosimilar and biob butter
markets so what we've learned from the
p800 plus system which I highlighted
with the the kits uh I showed earlier is
that within the quality by design
process of monit antibody generation
that um we found it it works quite well
in generally in analytics and uh as
shown in this figure uh is well
integrated into about two-thirds of the
process and it's it's worked quite well
for these characterizations as it's it's
fed down the line but what we're we're
learning is that um greater sensitivity
in through quot is necessary earlier in
these processes and so we're we're
excited about um as I believe I'll
describe in the next Slide the the
capabilities of coupling capillar
electris with mass spectrometry to start
to address some of these challenges that
are that are further Upstream in the
quality by design
process so here shows our new cesi 8000
cap elector freis system for doing Mass
spectrometry coupled to the ab 5600
triple toop system and you can see that
uh they're coupled here in the middle
through a uh specially designed
interface that click clicks into the
nanor spray Source on a uh 5600
mometer and what's what's really
important to note about this this
connection is that it's at an extremely
ultra low flow rate so uh these
separations and electr spray ionization
processes are being done at in a flow
rate range that's less than 30
nanoliters per minute and so I'll over
the next couple of slides I'll start to
illustrate why uh this flow rate is so
important but essentially what we're
doing is we're coupling high high
resolution capill elector frees
separations with high resolution and
high sensitivity Mass vetry on this 5600
triple top
system so the way this Capal electris
process is being integrated with
electrospray ionization and ultimately
through Mass ometry is with a porous tip
so this figure here illustrates what
we're calling
cesi the integration of cap
electropheresis with electrosphere
ionization into a single Dynamic process
within the same device and this this is
important because this is fundamentally
different than uh other methodologies
for doing cap capillary electr Rees with
mass
Petry uh in this case what's what's done
is a capillary is etched to the point
where the tip is POR so you can see this
PO segment of the capillary here and
what this allows us to do is make an
electrical connection with a electrode
this would be a essentially a standard
electr spray ionization needle through a
conductive liquid that's introduced in
between this pores tip and the the metal
needle and so as a result when we're
doing electros spray ionization we're
actually only
introducing the flow from the CE
separation into the mometer and that's
really why we get these these ultra low
flow rates at less than 30 naners per
minute because we we're capable of only
introducing the flow from the C
separation and I forgot to briefly
mention on that last slide if you're
more interested you could look at the
publication by
Moen which was
shown so the way this
this is integrated then and implemented
is through a commercial interface so
that design has now been manufactured
into this CSI 8000 cartridge and some of
the advantages of this are um as
highlighted at the bottom of the slide
that there's really just a single
capillary that's running from the from
the inlet of the the cartridge all the
way to the the outlet and essentially
there's the etch tip at the very tip of
the end of the the capillary and at the
inlet that is the same capillary so
because of that the single cap capillary
design allows this to be done these low
flow rate separations to be done with no
fluidic connections and it really
simplifies than the the nanoflow
separations of mass trometry so we're
not only getting the advantages of
capillar electri freis separations which
I highlighted as being more efficient
than U LC separations but we're also
getting these ultra low Nan per minute
flow
rates uh something else notable about
these cartridges is that they have
retractable uh protective housings on
both
the uh capillaries that
are at the inlets of the capillaries and
at the outlet and uh so just again
pointing to one ities that's one of the
retractable housings protective housings
and this other capillary actually on the
right side that I just pointed to is
what is used for introduction of the the
sheath sorry not sheath the conductive
liquid which allows for connection of
the the electrical connection of the uh
electric spray voltage to that porest
tip that porest segment of the of the
capillary okay so why why are these
ultra low nanoliter per minute flow
rates so important and what this really
comes from is a there's a large body of
literature that shows that going down to
ultra low Nan per minute flow rates is
is really important uh to improve
sensitivity um reduce ion suppression
and um ultimately ionize some some
really challenging molecules so this
this last publication is a review and it
it shows that um a lot of these really
challenging biological
molecules for electros iation that uh
this uh Nan essentially Nano electr
spray is has a lot of improvements for
doing these type of separate separations
and and uh ionizations and analyses of
these
molecules so if you just conceptually
think of how electr spray Works uh the
reason these ultra low flow rates are so
important is due to the fact that you
get better ionization efficien
and reduced ion suppression through
better better desolvation of these
molecules so if you look at a high flow
condition here these these droplets that
are coming out of whatever separation
you're performing they they're large and
they require more more energy to to
desolvate into ions and so when you go
to these ultra low Flor rates the
droplets are smaller and ultimately the
the ions are generated more quickly and
more efficiently so by going to these
these ultra low flow rates we're getting
as you'll see in some of these results
really increased sensitivity and
decreased ion
supression and this just these results
just illustrate this so this is a
infusion of angiotensin at different
flow rates and you can see that um when
you're at flow rates that are um
High you have very low sensitivity in
terms of counts per mole but as you go
to lower flow rates you see this
exponential increase and ultimately this
this maximization of sensitivity at
around 10 naners per minute so you can
see that it's it's really advantageous
to be be below 50 nanoliters per minute
and operating in this High
sensitivity uh electr spray ionization
regime and just to put this into context
with some of the other current
separation technologies that are
available for doing analysis of
biomolecules in general you can see that
um the cesims is really the only one
that's capable of doing these these
types of separations and Ultra lowf
flow ionization processes so even Nano
nanop lcms is still above that kind of
50 Nan per minute cut off range where
you start to reduce
sensitivity
uh to continue illustrating the the
benefits of these ultra low Nano flow
rates uh you can see a comparison of
equimolar infusion of neurotensin which
is a peptide and MTO
heos mohos is shown on the right which
is a a difficult to ionize molecule and
so by doing this at ultralow fluides you
can see we get equal when you mix them
in equal amounts this group found that
that they get ecomar response but when
you go to high flow rates uh it Essen
the mapos is essentially absent so there
is still some ionization but you can see
that it's surely not an equal equ amount
so you already are may be starting to
get the idea that there are surely some
benefits of doing uh these ultra low
flow separations and electr spray
through uh looking at at some of these
more challenging molecules like a
multipose and this uh this is quite
similar in structure to glycans which
you can imagine have would have some
benefits for glycopeptide analysis so
later in this presentation you'll see
the benefits of of this with
glycopeptide
analysis additionally focusing on
peptides again phosphopeptides are known
to be some of the more challenging
molecules to analyze you can see that
with uh increasing numbers of
phosphorated residues on these
synthesized peptides that the ionization
efficiency goes down dramatically as you
increase the number of phosphates and
this was done at 100 nanoliters or
greater than 100 nanoliters per minute
but when you do the same experiment of
infusion at 10 naners per minute you can
see that some of
the these very difficult to phosphorate
sorry very diff difficult to ionize
phosphorate peptides actually have
better response and if you go to a
different charge State such as this
doubly
charged uh version of the same peptides
you can see that they actually have
equal essentially equal response so
again this illustrates the advantages of
ionizing difficult to ionize
molecules uh using these ultra low flow
rates so the there's other advantages
also where
just using the CSI th000 Edge infusion
device uh including looking at protein
dimer Lian complexes so in this case
this is a published example of mixing a
beta ring protein with a p14 peptide can
and you can see with these ultral FL
rates and the appropriate buffer that
you're actually able to measure the each
of the St geometries of those those
binding
interactions
uh similarly looking at large protein
complexes is another great possibility
for this CSI 8000 device you can see
that the analysis of
hemos uh as different complex forms with
the largest
being 18mer of 1.3 megadaltons and also
other forms of zamer and a hexamer with
this analysis being performed at 10 Nan
per minute um essentially use only 7 4
nanoliters during this time of analysis
which is dramatically smaller than the
equivalent 100 microl that would
normally be used in in an ESI experiment
so this the CSI uh system allows to do
these typees of infusion experiments
where you can monitor uh complexes and
actually ionize them without without
much
difficulty so you can imagine that the
analysis of large molecules would be
beneficial with with monola antibodies
okay so I'll shift gears a little bit
now and get specifically into the
characterization of biologics which I'm
sure you guys are most interested in in
this case we'll focus on a monal
antibody I had previously highlighted
the uh some of these modifications that
occur on Mon antibodies and I'll show
these now as potential critical quality
attributes and you can see that uh
there's a number of these that we had
listed before that are now highlight in
red which are actually the what we're
capable of getting from a single cesi Ms
analysis using a single uh digest using
Trion so we'll talk more about these
these modifications and how we're able
to get uh get information about all of
these from a single
analysis as I mentioned this using
csims with one protease and one digest
we're getting 100 % peptide coverage in
less than an hour of of analysis time I
had already alluded to glycan analysis
or glycopeptide analysis and so what
I'll show you is we're getting broad
dynamic range um identification of the
amino acid linkage of these glycans on
peptides since we're analyzing them as
glycopeptides and additionally since
we're actually able to separate them
using C so we get a migration pattern
that's associated with the the different
sizes and charges of the glycans on the
peptides and using the accurate mass and
the uh high resolution msms to of the
mass spectrometer that allows us to
simplify the identification
collectively we're also as I alluded to
characterizing a number of these
potential critical quality attributes uh
that are shown
here so for the analysis we're we're
really not using any special tricks
we're doing a standard uh digestion of
these monoclonal
antibodies using uh denat denaturization
using uh water's rapid Gest and just
standard reduction alkal and so we
reduce the reduce the monol anbody and
then digest it with
Tron and then with those tryptic
peptides we just do a standard CSI Ms
run and from those results then we're
use typically using protein pilot
software to search for for modifications
uh one advantage of using protein pilot
is that we're we're capable of searching
for uh more than 300 different post
transational modifications on these on
these proteins um without much
challenge uh there's also another piece
of software that's been recently
introduced called biofarm view which is
an efficient lcms and
cesims data processing for
Biotherapeutics and so you can see just
an example here with the with the search
that we can get um 100% coverage of both
the heavy and the light chain and what
this also allows us to do is extract out
all of the
different uh Peaks the electrooptic
Peaks here for these peptides from an
from an analysis and notably the
modified residues which have post
transation modifications on them are
shown in red within within the sequence
so this this software can be used
actually for both uh these peptide
mapping experiments and intact uh
protein analysis and I believe there is
a technical note available on the abses
website if you're interested in learning
more about these more about this
software so to demonstrate the
characterization capabilities of csims
we've been mostly looking at trab which
is a well-characterized monoclonal
antibody I'm you're probably familiar
with it it's it's a humanized
igg1
that's raised against the her two
receptor uh invasive an invasive breast
cancer it has two heavy and light
chains and also a heavy chain Ang hosell
consensus site at sparing
300 and because it has a number of
well-characterized post transation
modifications we're able to Benchmark
our capabilities for looking at uh
deorative hotpots
which are often stability indicators and
also glyco
variants so as you can see from from
these results here with csims we're
capable of getting one 100% coverage of
both the heavy and light chain with one
digest in one injection and if you look
closely there's there's actually some
additional information that's gained
from overlapping peptide sequences so
you can start to get the idea that we're
getting identification of both very
small and very large peptide sequences
using
csims and one of the advantages of
that's actually one of the advantages of
using CSI is we do get these small
identification of these small and very
large peptides so the largest one
identified here is the
63 and in comparison to LC
separations uh what's particularly
unique about C is that we're separating
we're actually separating both the small
and large peptides the whole range of
peptides with very good efficiency so
when you when you may often see small
peptides come out in the dead volume of
your LC separation or uh some of these
larger peptides may have poor Peak
shapes or
intensities with LC they actually both
of these uh sizes of peptides have very
good efficiencies and uh sensitivities
with with CSI
Ms additionally since we're capable of
getting these highquality uh Peak shapes
and also MSM
identifications you can see uh in this
publication by kah at all that they're
capable of getting unique B Andy ion
fragments which give direct information
for each amino acid so in that the
variable domain of the heavy chain of
trab they're able to identify 120 out of
120 of the amino acids by specifically
by B and Y ions in the msms Spectra and
also for the light chain they were they
showed they were able to get almost all
than 105 out of7 so in this in this
variable domain region where the
sequence information is very important
uh CSI gives you the capabilities of
getting the majority of those amino
acids directly identified from the
peptide sequences
additionally so I briefy mentioned earli
in the presentation biosimilar so this
this slide shows the capabilities of
csims for comparing a tusab and a
biosimilar of
tusab so by this comparison of these
these peptide sequences you can see that
uh lysine 217 has been converted to
Arginine 217 within the the biosimilar
so the sensitivity and uh sequence
coverage of csims of monol antibodies is
really what facilitates
this uh this uh
analysis and at this point I just want
to briefly thank uh anise Nicholas Fran
at the University of Strasburg France
for sharing these results with
us okay so in addition to getting 100%
sequence coverage and very good uh
sequence variant analysis you can also
see that we're going to focus on the
capabilities of using csims for
characterizing deorative PTM hotspots
and some of the known ones listed here
on trab such as pyroglutamate
formation uh lysine truncation methine
oxidation and
deamidation of a spar Gene are common
and characterized on Trista but are also
very important in the generally in the
characterization of other monoc
antibodies so the first example we have
here shows the parag glutamate
characterization you can see that we're
easily able to separate the modified and
unmodified version of those peptides
with very good Peak shapes SE and
separation efficiency and also get very
high quality msms Spectra for uh the
inter terminal pyroglutamate
peptide
additionally if you look at methine
oxidation we're also capable of uh
characterizing that within this single
analyses
uh from these msms Spectra shown which
are of high quality and in the case
where methine oxidation or methine
oxidized peptides aren't actually
separated from from the uh unmodified
peptide we're really taking advantage of
the capabilities of this CS with the
ultra low flow separation so you can see
that even though these These are of low
abundance we're having no trouble um
still identifying them and and also
quantifying them as I'll show in the
next in a few slides
yet so the the fact that there's really
reduced ion suppression is what what's
allowing us to still characterize some
of the any of these peptides that are
remain
unseparated so here's another example
from this same analysis where we're able
to get C terminal Ling hyrogen
characterization so you can see uh
identifying and quantifying both of
these peptides with or without the C
terminal
Ling and this example shows the
identification and characterization of a
spare Gene deamidation so there's a
number of different uh sites and
peptides which were identified on uh the
trus that we analyzed and so you can see
that notably we're able to actually
separate the unmodified from the
modified
peptides and why this is important is
because deamidation is a modification
that can occur along many different
steps of the process including during
the analysis so the capability of
separating these actually can
differentiate whether a deamidation
occurs during some form of the electr
spray process or even during mass
spectrometry so so for some of these um
Peaks where you can still see some of
the you can see a deamidated form for
instance in this case under the uh
unmodified form that this this
deamidation must have occurred during
say the electr spray process or the mass
spectrometry process instead of um this
peak here which was an already present
at the beginning of your
analysis so you can also see that
there's uh some additional Peaks that
arise from from asparagine
deamination
and what's been quite interesting is
recently uh Gul at all have been able to
show that we we're able to characterize
those other Peaks that arise uh using
csims and what those are are um both
aspartic acid form from theagene
deamidation and also AAR isoaspartic
acid so that is just the rized version
verion of aspartic acid so the the two
peaks that are shown here are actually
from differentiating the ASP and the iso
ASP so what's what's not about notable
about this is if you look at the mass
mass Spectra shown here uh the top one
in B shows the deaminated form and the
lower one shows the spartic acid form so
those can both be we can both separate
them by C and we can also differentiate
them by msms however because the
aspartic acid and isoaspartic acid are
isobaric or have the same mass they'll
actually have the same exact msms
Spectra as shown in C and so the the
capabilities of separating them by the
CSI gives you the a way of actually
analyzing them separately and the way
this group confirmed this is by spiking
in different amounts of the synthesized
isos spartic acid so you can see with
this figure that essentially the they're
separated and the as you increase the
amount of isoaspartic acid that Peak
also increases and the aspartic acid one
decreases which gives confirmation of
this rization of the spartic
acid okay so i' mentioned all of these
analyses are being generated from single
runs of the
CSI from a single digest but we've also
run these in in replicates and you can
see for um all of these modifications
I've listed in addition there's also
lysing glycation and tryptophan
dioxidation that we've looked at that
the identifications are all very very
good in terms of mass accuracy and also
the in triplicates the the relative
abundances of these are all uh very well
measured uh from run to run so this
gives you a great way of doing relative
quantification of these modifications
with very good reproducibility between
runs of
CSI okay so now um I'll talk about some
of the surely the most
challenging peptides that analyze on a
monocom antibody and these are the
glycopeptides um there's a number of
different gly forms that are present and
known on trusa and so we've been been
able to demon demonstrate that CSI is
capable of characterizing these these
very difficult to analyze
glycopeptides um with very good coverage
and dynamic
range so here's an example of
characterizing and again this is all
from the exact same run just from a
single trip of digest and a single
analysis we're we're capable of getting
these separations and identifications of
of these glycopeptides so you can see in
the top the top left figure these are
the AP culated forms of the
glycopeptides uh that were identified
the lower Trace here on the left is
the uh different pated forms and the
trace on the right shows some of the
more difficult more highly branched less
abundant a few of these are cic contain
cic acid which induces a large migration
shift relative to the other
glycopeptides so notably you can see
with all of these traces were we're
capable of separating these
glycopeptides and getting very good
sensitivity even for some of these ones
that are of very low abundance and
of higher branching and potentially more
more difficult to
identify uh similarly
um because there's some peptides formed
glycopeptides form with a larger
sequence we're also getting additional
information quantitative and
identification information about these
glycopeptides so this slide shows
the uh the glycopeptides that are
identified on the longer form of the
peptide and collectively grouping these
these identification and quantification
results together we're able to generate
this table showing that we can identify
20 glycopeptides on trus MTH in a single
run from the same runs that we're
getting these other sequence variants
and uh Digger to PTM identifications
quantifications from so similar to the
Digger of ptms we're also getting very
good ma Mass accuracy again on these
glycopeptides and you also look at
the relative abundance characterization
you can see we're going somewhere from
55% down to I believe it's
.6% with very good uh relative standard
deviations for for each one of those in
triplicate runs so this really gives you
a great great great capabilities for
doing glycopeptide or glycan
characterization on your monoc antibody
with very good
reproducibility uh between these
runs and again talking about biosimilars
uh glycosilation characterization is
going to be very important for comparing
biosimilars to the innovators so these
these uh figures show the Gan profile in
as glycopeptides of cmab and a
biosimilar trab b and also sumab and a
biosimilar of
suab as
B and by doing these comparisons you can
see that in both of these cases the gly
the glycan and glycopeptide th profiles
are
different so again I'd just like to
briefly thank uh yanis Nicholas franois
University of strawsburg France for
these for these great results that we
were able to share with you
today so to begin to summarize the
capabilities of high sensitivity csims
are that we're able to get Pur analysis
through these 100% peptide mapping
coverages again from a single run and a
single tryptic digest we're able to
assess Purity and stability which are
indicated by a number of these deorative
ptms that we discussed and also this
excellent gcop Ty coverage and
characterization and ultimately because
you're able to do this on a single
analysis you're getting all the
information you need in a single
separation with complete coverage and
many of these either potential or
actually critical critical quality
attributes which ultimately saves you
time so what we're really hoping is that
this will not only fit into some of the
existing places that CE is used in
biopharma but that will'll also work
further up into the the development
pipeline where
people or you may be limited by um the
amount of sample you have or dynamic
range or
sensitivity okay so just to highlight
again the benefits in general of csims
we're getting this reduced ion
suppression which really gives us the
the capabilities to get increased
sensitivity for some of these really
challenging molecules to analyze because
we're using Cal electric freis we also
get this very high efficiency separation
that just in
to
C also I haven't really highlighted this
too much but because we're using the CE
for these separations which typically
take 45 minutes with with a small
equilibration time before each run we're
actually getting decreased injection
action injection time for these analyses
so a single analysis of this takes about
an
hour uh similarly with the equilibration
period at the front of the the C
separation before each run we're
essentially getting no carryover between
between these analyses and much of this
comes from the fact that there's no
solid support within the capillary it's
just an open tube so anything you you
inject out of the capillary comes off
and that's also part of the reason we're
getting these uh great coverages of all
the way from small up to very large
peptides from these monola
antibodies uh additionally we're getting
broad analy coverage so I showed you
examples of the superior peptide mapping
coverage all the way up to non-covalent
complex characterization so there's the
potential for a lot of different for
using this this system for a lot of
different types of analyses you may be
interested in and ultimately um we're
also reducing some of the artifacts
because we have the electr spray
ionization voltage much lower than
what's typically used we're often using
around one kilovolt for these for these
ESI processes and also um we're
isolating the electr spray ionization
voltage from any of the analyes that
you're interested in analyzing through
the manufactured tip that we
have so just briefly I'll show you again
here's the CSI th000 uh one notable
thing I didn't mention is this this is
included with a cart that can
automatically raise and lower the the
system to match your mass spectrometer
height and again here's a example of the
cartridge which just clicks into the map
into the cesi 8000 and then also clicks
into the adapter that's designed for uh
your mass
petrometer uh speaking of clicking it
into a mass petrometer here are uh
images that show the integration of this
with the ab triple toop 5600 system
which I'd shown briefly before so we're
capable of connecting it to the 5600 and
also there is an adapter available for
the thermoscientific cubes active
mometer so a number of the results I
mentioned today were uh in Publications
which I would point you to look at if
you're more interested in looking at any
of these results but we also have two uh
csims technical notes which are
available on our website
www.x.com so I would invite you to look
at these more closely if you're
interested in learning more about these
the capabilities of CSI m as for doing
uh these peptide mapping experiments to
characterize all these different
modifications in a single run with a
single
digest so in summary uh C is a robust
and reliable technique that's well
integrated into biopharma uh development
and control processes and so we're
really excited about the capabilities of
cesi and how that might start fitting
into the these different processes with
CE already demonstrating many useful
capabilities
as I mentioned before cesi is the
integration of Capal electris with
electr spray ionization serving to
reduce eliminate ion suppression and
increase ion efficiency so the
capabilities of these ultral low flow
rates are really improving uh the
analysis of a lot of these molecules
we're starting to look at and from a
single an single run of a therapeutic
monoclonal antibody digest as I had
shown CSI can provide peptide map with
100% coverage protection of critical PTM
such as degradation hotspots
identification of glyco variants with
ultra high sensitivity and that broad
dynamic range as I showed with 20
identifying 20 of the glycopeptides on
trus and now courtesy of Janice Nicholas
fris we're really excited about the
capabilities of CSI for uh comparing
these innovator monoc antibodies with
biosimilar monoc antibodies and
hopefully what you've gathered from this
presentation is really that flow rate
matter so in addition to being able to
do these separations with C the fact
that we're able to do these analyses at
these ultra low Nan per minute flow
rates you really start to see some of
the molecules that are very difficult to
identify with some some of these
traditional techniques hopefully you'll
find that this will be useful for some
of the some of the molecules that you'll
be interested that you're currently
interested in looking at and will be
interested at looking at in the
future okay so thank you again at this
point I will pass pass this over to
Stephanie who will uh start the Q&A
session for
us hey everyone uh this is Stephanie and
I'd like to start by thanking Ryan for
that informative presentation just a
quick reminder before we get started
going through your questions uh you can
submit your questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which is found by clicking
the green Q&A button in the lower left
presentation window and we're going to
try to get to as many questions as we
can today and so with that um Brian our
first question comes from Scott Wagner
at biovest International Incorporated
and he wants to know can a client send
you sample for analysis to see what kind
of data we can generate they have an
autologus a DC product and with that
I'll switch back to
Brian thank you that's a good question
uh we do have a active demo sample
analysis
program uh I would ask that if you are
interested in submitting your samples um
I guess I'm unsure of the capabilities
us you contacting us but we can surely
send you an email there's also a place
on the website I believe where you
can um send us I guess ping us and send
us a little note more with um more of
the details of your analysis but we're
very very interested in in demonstrating
the capabilities with this particularly
on on customer samples which which may
be different than some of the things
that we worked with thus
far so I'll pass that back to St
well thanks for for answering that our
next question comes from Gary Lee at
emergent bio Solutions and he wants to
know do you need to do a Del salt step
before digestion if yes how do you do
that and back to you
Brian thanks that's another good
question uh typically in the anales that
I've performed and other applications
scientists have performed um we're not
doing any desalting steps for these
peptide mapping experiments uh we do
have a standard protocol that could be
followed as I mentioned using rapid and
some of the standard uh reducing and
ulating
agents
oh thanks our next question comes from
Mike Maloy from uh GSK and he wants to
know can you identify the glycin
peptides and get a glycin profile from
the experiment also how does the data
compare to release gayen
data thank you Mike so I I may have
missed part of that question but um I
believe the first part was whether we
can get these these
profiles and so I guess just to
briefly try to get back to one of these
slides here this one this is the case
where we're comparing you know a bio
similar to an innovator of tusab or
suaab and you can see that we can get
these these profiles plotted like this
or as I showed in
in another slide if I can find this
quick this table
of of
glycopeptides that essentially give you
that profile so you can see the relative
abundance of these in triplicate that
show the uh the profile then of these
these glycans measured as
glycopeptides and I have seen some uh
comparison of these directly to
our uh released and glycan C
L using capill G
electris and they indeed look uh quite
close I guess if you'd like to see any
more of that that data we could uh
surely get in in contact with you and
discuss that
further so I'll pass this back to
Stephan thanks uh our next question
comes from Roxanna g at the University
of British Columbia and she would like
to know how were the structures of the
glycin portion of the glycopeptides
identified and was this performed using
uh ms/ms
analysis thank you roxan for the
question yes so the I guess I didn't
show that in any of these slides but
we're we're using just
msms um identification of the glyco
peptides and what we're seeing is
generally a you know fragman for both
the peptide and uh some of the important
uh low molecular weight glycan
structures which give us that
identification so it's really coupling
both of those things from the msms with
the high mass
accuracy U measurement of the intact
glycopeptide so collectively with all
those high
resolution uh Ms and Ms Ms MS2
measurements that that's what allows us
to get those glycopep identifications
and additionally as I briefly mentioned
um what's nice hopefully the slide is
showing up okay so I'll show this one
that by extracting those uh
ms1 ions over time and these extracted
ion electrograms that were actually able
to you know see that there's a peak
associated with each one of these
glycopeptides so by having all the msms
and Ms information and also seeing a
nicely shaped Peak that really gives us
additional information that U that
glycopeptide is indeed true and there
thank you that was a good
question thanks um our next question
comes from swin suart from fronhofer dof
can you tell tell me the amount of
antibody you used for the sequence
coverage estimation experiments and back
to you
Brian thank you that's another good
question uh sorry I actually forgotten
to meas mention that um from the
majority of the experiments we're using
between uh 100 and 200 nanog of the
samples so we would typically you know
prepare you know 50 micrograms of sample
and then perform a small injection of
you know 100 to 200 nanograms and that's
that's what allows us to get these 100%
sequence coverages and additionally
identify all of these
different uh sequence variants and
modifications so from that single
analysis of 100 to 200 nanograms that's
what we're we're capable of doing thank
you for that question I'll pass this
back to
Stephanie okay um again apologies for
any mispronunciations of names our next
question comes from deser harar from
aminocore
transplant and they would like to know
what is the initial purity of the
Protein that's required for this type of
analysis
thanks that's a good question uh
typically for these analyses we're using
um fairly peer monol antibodies so in
the case of trus map since that's a a
marketed therapeutic it's quite pure but
we're beginning to start to look at um
how these how looking at impurities of
these analyses uh could be beneficial
for for C bio biopharma customer
um so such as host cell proteins but
unfortunately at this point I I can't
think of any data off the top of my head
that that might better answer your
question but that's surely something
we're we're uh interested in focusing on
in the near future so hopefully we can
reach out to you and and discuss that a
little bit
more so thank you and I'll pass this
back to
Stephanie okay uh our next question
comes from Mara s T from ABX how can you
experimentally determine if oxidation or
deamidation is in the sample or due to
the a ESI process and back to you
Brian thanks Mara that's a good question
uh so as I mentioned one of the the ways
we can do that is we can try to find
this slide
quickly uh one of the ways we can do
this is actually by
separating uh in the case of deamidation
you can separate these so if there's uh
any any form of deamidation that occurs
under the asparagine peak that's likely
due to something with ESI or the mass
spectrometer and this guess sorry I
should be pointing at these
quickly so essentially uh this this peak
here shown if there's any deamidation
directly under the the
unmodified peak that would likely be due
to something during the process or um
during the ESI process or the micrometry
process whereas a peak that
appears
um such as this one from the SP
amidation is likely due to something
prior to the analysis since they were
separated during the C
process so in the case of methine
oxidation since we're actually not
resolving these
uh I think the way that you would
attempt to and you could also do this
for for sparing deamidation is do some
kind of time course to show that um this
changes over time due to something
that's occurring in solution versus
something that's occurring during the
analysis so I don't know of any examples
where we we've tried that yet but that's
surely the strategy I would think that
that could be used for that thank you
for that question I'll pass this
back
unfortunately we are out of time for
today I want to thank everyone who
attended for your interesting questions
and participation in today's event I'd
also like to thank our sponsors scx
separations for making today's
educational webcast
possible